in this video we're going to go through
a first quarter precalculus exam review
there's timestamps in the description
below if you want to hop to a particular
part of this video well let's jump into
this video and we'll go through the
problems together here so number one
says determine the quadrant or quadrants
where the coordinate XY is located such
that x / y is less than zero okay so
what they're testing us on here is that
we're familiar with our four quadrants
in the first quadrant the X is positive
and the Y is positive and the second
quadrant the X is negative in the Y is
positive and the third quadrant both the
X and the y are negative and in the
fourth quadrant the X is positive and
the Y is negative but notice when you
divide the x and y in order to get a
number less than zero meaning negative
one of the values has to be positive one
of the values has to be negative so
that's only going to occur here in the
second and fourth quadrant I'll just
write that using Roman numerals two and
four okay so definitely something to
memorize there number two it says find
the distance and the midpoint between
two negative three and negative three
nine now you might want to pause the
video some of these problems see if you
can do them on your own and kind of
check them with me as we go through this
but important formulas you might want to
add to your study sheet or your formula
sheet would be the distance formula x2
minus x1 squared plus y2 minus y1
squared then you add them together and
take the square root so if we do the
distance you can see that this is like
0.1 x1 y1 this is 0.2 we call that x2 y2
so we're going to subtract the
x-coordinates we've got negative 3 minus
2 squared and we're going to subtract
the y-coordinates so that's going to be
9 minus negative 3 squared add those
together and take the square root so
negative 3 minus 2 is negative 5
negative 5 squared is 25 9 minus a
negative 3 is like 9 plus 3 that's 12 12
squared is 144 if we add those together
we get the square root of 169 which is
equal to 13 so that's the distance
between these two points now for the
midpoint another form you want to
memorize or at your study sheet here
your formula
she is x1 plus x2 divided by 2 and y1
plus y2 divided by 2 like that so what
you're doing is it's like an average
you're adding the XS together and
dividing by 2 and then you're adding the
Y's together and dividing by 2 and that
will give you the point in the middle so
for this one what we're going to do is
we're going to say 2 plus negative 3
divided by 2 and we've got negative 3
plus 9 divided by 2 now all we have to
do is simplify this is going to give us
negative 1/2 and this is going to give
us 6 divided by 2 which is 3 so you can
see our midpoint is that negative 1/2
comma 3 okay so for number 3 now it says
find the x and y intercepts of the graph
so intercepts just means where does it
cross that x axis or the y axis right so
what you can do if you remember this
from earlier in math is you can make a
little table like this just set X to 0
to find the y intercept set Y to 0 to
find the x intercept so you're setting
the opposite variable equal to 0 so if
we put 0 in for X here you can see
that's going to be 3 times 0 which is 0
plus 1 is 1 the square root of 1 is 1
right so you can see that the y
intercept here is going to be at 0 comma
1 now for the y intercept I'm sorry I
said that rocket is for the x intercept
we're going to set Y to 0 right so if we
put 0 and for y we just have to solve
for X now so if we square both sides of
this equation 0 squared is still 0 if we
subtract 1 from both sides you can see
we've got 3x equals negative 1
divide both sides by 3 and you can see
that our x intercept is negative 1/3
comma 0 so this just kind of helps you
when you're graphing 0 1 would be right
here and negative 1/3 comma 0 would be
like right about here and so now you
have an idea about what the graph is
going to look like ok or at least a
couple key points okay so for number 4
see if you can try this one it says
write the standard form of the equation
of a circle with the center at 0
negative 2 and the diameter of 6 okay so
another important formula you want to
add to your formula sheet here is the
standard form of the equation of a
circle so it's X minus H squared
plus y minus K squared equals the radius
squared
so H and K that represents the center
point R represents the radius but then
you're going to square it okay so this
comes from the distance formula well
let's see if we can substitute these
values in so we've got X minus 0 squared
plus y minus negative 2 squared now the
diameter is 6 which means that the
radius is equal to 3 so 3 squared is 9
now I can simplify this a little bit
more X minus 0 is just X so we could say
x squared here when you subtract a
negative it's like adding the opposite
so that's y plus 2 squared equals 9 so
that's your standard form of your
equation of your circle ok for number 5
now see if you can do this one it says
if negative 3 4 is on a graph name
another point that must be on the graph
if the graph has origin symmetry okay so
what does that mean origin symmetry well
for example let's look at a graph that
has origin symmetry say for example like
y equals x cubed see if you take a point
here and you rotate it 180 degrees about
the origin and it would match up with a
corresponding point right there
so our tests for origin symmetries like
this X Y ok so basically you can find
the corresponding point by multiplying
the x and y values by negative 1 and
what that does is that rotates that
figure about the origin so in this case
negative 3 for a corresponding point
would be positive 3 negative 4 and you
got it okay number 6 it says the graph y
equals 2x cubed minus X has symmetry
with respect to the x-axis y-axis or
origin ok so here's the test that you
want to memorize when you're testing to
see if it's a reflection okay over the
x-axis meaning it has symmetry with the
x axis what you want to do is you want
to replace X and y with X comma negative
Y so this is x axis symmetry and if you
want to test for y axis symmetry what
you do is replace the ax in the equation
with negative x and the y with positive
Y so that's why axis symmetry and then
if you're testing for origin symmetry
you replace both X with negative x and Y
with negative Y
and what happens is when you replace
those and you do those substitutions and
you simplify if you get the original
equation back that tells you that it has
symmetry with regard to that x-axis
y-axis or origin so I'll show you what I
mean so in this first one see X and
negative y if we replace Y with negative
Y and X just with X when we look at that
equation see even if I multiply
everything by negative one y equals
negative two x cubed plus X see how I'm
not getting back the original equation
that tells us that it's not symmetric
with regard to the x-axis now let's test
the other one let's say we replace X
with negative x and Y with positive Y so
here we get y equals two times negative
x cubed minus negative x but when we
simplify a negative to an odd power is a
negative so that gives us negative 2x
cubed and a negative times a negative is
a positive but you can see we're not
getting back that original equation so
that tells us it's not symmetric about
the y-axis now for the origin we're
replacing both the X and the y okay with
negative x with negative Y and when we
simplify here let's see what happens we
have negative y equals negative 2x cubed
plus X if I multiply everything by
negative one to get this to be a
positive Y the signs are going to flip
and when we look at that we see oh it's
the same as the original equation so
this tells us that it has rotation about
the origin so you might want to add
these to your note sheet for testing the
different types of symmetry okay let's
go to number seven it says find equation
of the line that passes through these
two points okay so you remember how to
find equations of lines first thing we
have to do is we have to find the slope
and remember the slope is y2 minus y1
over x2 minus x1 so I'm going to say
four minus five which is negative one
and negative one minus two which is
negative three the two negatives cancel
so you can see our slope is 1/3 now you
probably also remember the point-slope
form of the equation of a line so x1 y1
is a point that the line goes through
and M is our slope so in this case I'm
just gonna put 1/3 and for M I'm just
gonna use this point over here to 5 so y
minus the y-coordinate
equals X minus the x-coordinate and then
if you want what you can do is you can
distribute the 1/3 so this is 1/3 X
minus 2/3 and then what I'm gonna do is
I'm going to add the 5 over here okay
now I'm just going to common
denominators this is 15 thirds minus 2
thirds which gives us 13 thirds okay and
that's our equation or a line in slope
intercept form but you could probably
leave it in the point-slope form that
would be fine too okay for number eight
now it says find the equation of the
line that's perpendicular to this line
and passes through this point so when we
talk about lines that are parallel
remember those have the same slope we
talk about lines that are perpendicular
they have opposite reciprocal slopes so
in this case we have to figure out what
the slope of this line is and what I'm
gonna do is I'm going to rearrange it by
subtracting 3x from both sides of the
equation if I divide everything by
negative 5 now we have it in slope
intercept form so we can see the slope
is 3/5 the perpendicular slope is going
to be negative 5/3 we know it's passing
through this point so I'm going to do Y
minus negative 2 equals negative 5/3 X
minus 3 and now you can see it's in the
point-slope form but let me simplify
this a little bit more distribute that's
going to give us negative 5/3 X plus 5
and this is y plus 2 and if we subtract
u from both sides we get negative 5/3 X
plus 3 and now it's in the
slope-intercept form okay let's try
number 9 so it says given that f of X
equals 2x squared minus X how would you
find f of X plus 2 so here they're
testing us on function notation how to
work with functions but remember
whatever is in the parentheses that goes
in for X on the right side of the
equation right but in this case this is
like our new input our new x-value so
what we're going to do is we're going to
replace X with X plus 2 so we get to
instead of X I'm going to put X plus 2
instead of X here I'm going to put X
plus 2 and now we just have to simplify
so X plus 2 squared really represents X
plus 2 times X plus 2
okay here I'm just going to distribute
the negative so that's going to be
negative X minus two here you can foil
this out you're just going to get x
squared plus 4x plus 4 all multiplied by
2 okay so this gives us 2x squared plus
8x plus 8 minus X minus 2 combine like
terms 8x minus 1 X is 7x and 8 minus 2
is 6 and that's your final result so
again it's just a substitution for
number 10 now it says given f of X
equals this piecewise function how would
you find F of negative 3 so notice that
with piecewise functions you're on this
graph when X is less than or equal to
negative 2 you're on this graph y equals
5 when you're in between negative 2 & 3
and then you're on this graph when X is
greater than 3 well when we look at
negative 3 here see how negative 3 is
less than or equal negative 2 that means
we're gonna be on this part of the graph
that part of the piecewise graph so all
we have to do now is replace X with what
x equals which is negative 3 so that's 3
times negative 3 minus 1 so it's
negative 9 minus 1 which is negative 10
okay so it's just basically trying to
figure out you know where does that x
value fall on which graph so for number
11 it says given f of X equals this
equation how would you find the zeros so
what does that mean when they say find
the zeros well zeros means that the Y
value f of X is like our output or Y
value is 0 so I'm going to do is I'm
going to set this whole equation equal
to 0 and then we're going to solve now
there's a couple different ways to do
this you can use the quadratic formula
you could factor you could complete the
square etc but for this one what I'm
going to do is I'm just going to factor
okay and you can see that this is going
to be positive 8 and negative 1 see 8 X
and negative 5 X gives you 3 X 8 x
megatonnes negative 8 5 x times 1 X is 5
x squared if you need help with
factoring check out some my factoring
videos on my Morrow's math tutoring
youtube channel and i can go over that
with you to show you how to factor
trinomials but now all you have to do is
set each group equal to 0 so I'm going
to say a 0 equals 5 X plus 8 and 0
equals X minus 1 so if we subtract 8
from both sides divide by 5
you can see that x equals negative 8/5
and if we add one to both sides here you
can see that x equals one so our zeros
are going to be 1 and negative 8/5 and
again what the zeros mean it's where y
equals 0 it's where it crosses the x
axis these are the X intercepts okay so
for number 12 now we're talking about
the domain so what is the domain well
the domain is whatever you can put into
the equation in place of X right the
range is what comes out those are the Y
values but for the domain you want to be
careful because you can't necessarily
put anything into this equation for
example we don't want this to be
negative because when you take the
square root of a negative you're needed
imaginary numbers so what we're going to
do is when you have square roots or 4th
roots or even roots take whatever is
underneath the radical and make it
greater than or equal to 0 so if I solve
this by subtracting 4 we get negative 3x
is greater than equal to negative 4
divide both sides by negative 3 but
remember when you divide or multiply an
inequality by a negative what happens
the inequality sign changes direction
right so now X is less than or equal to
4/3 sometimes it's helpful to graph this
on the number line so it's 4/3
or less so when we write this in
interval notation you could write it an
inequality notation but interval
notation would be like this negative
infinity to 4/3 including 4/3 right
because it includes that point but it
doesn't include negative 3 you can't
reach negative infinity you want to go
from left to right okay but for Part B
though now we have a fresh and with
fractions you don't want to divide by
zero that's undefined so when you have a
fresh and make sure that denominator is
not equal to 0 we're going to
temporarily set it equal to 0 to find
out what X would make the equations that
denominator 0 right so I'm going to add
1 to both sides so 3x equals 1 I'm going
to divide by 3 so x equals 1/3 but
really we don't want X to be 1/3 because
we don't want it in either to be equal
to 0 right so again if we go to the
number line here's 1/3 it could be all
of these values can't be 1/3 and it
could be all those values so the domain
is what X can be so it's everything but
1/3 now if we write this in interval
notation you can see it's negative
infinity
to one-third not including one through
that's why I'm writing the parentheses
Union one-third to positive infinity so
you want to think about going from low
to high or left to right okay question
number 13 it says given f of X equals 3x
squared minus 2x find the difference
quotient and remember the difference
quotient is f of X plus h minus f of X
all over H don't get this confused with
the derivative which we'll be learning a
little bit later in precalculus and
Indic calculus where you're finding the
limit as H approaches zero here we're
just finding the difference quotient so
the way you work with these ones is
again it's just like what we talked
about earlier about working with
functions whatever is in the parenthesis
that goes in four acts on the right now
if there's more than one X you would
replace both axes with that X plus h so
just think of it as a substitution so
what we have is three times X plus h
squared minus two times X plus h okay
now minus f of X now when you think of f
of X that's this entire function but
where some students make a mistake as
they forget to put it in parenthesis
because you're really subtracting right
here f of X this whole original equation
okay and then it's all divided by H so
now we just have to do a lot of
arithmetic you want to be a little bit
careful here so when you foil out X plus
h squared remember this is X plus h
times X plus h so that's going to come
out to x squared plus 2xh plus h squared
if you need to just write this X plus h
2 X plus h do the distributive property
twice or foil here we're going to
distribute the negative two so this
gives us negative 2x minus 2h and then
here we're gonna distribute the negative
that's going to give us negative 3x
squared plus 2x all divided by H now let
me see if I can distribute the 3 here so
this gives us 3x squared plus 6x H plus
3 H squared minus 2 X minus 2 H minus 3
x squared plus 2 X so you can see it's
quite tedious you have to be careful
you'll make little mistakes arithmetic
mistakes but now we're going to combine
like terms now notice the 3 x squared
and the negative 3x squared cancel the
2x and the negative 2x cancel so we're
just left with 6x
h plus 3 h squared minus 2h all / h
notice there's an h and each one of
these terms in the numerator so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to factor out
that H so 6 X plus 3 h minus 2 all
divided by H we can cancel the H is out
and our difference quotient is just
going to be 6 X plus 3 h minus 2 and you
got it okay let's look at number 14 here
it says state whether the function is
increasing decreasing or constant mm-hmm
now remember it's just like reading for
your left to right if the graph is going
up to the right that's like a positive
slope that's like increasing right if
it's going down to the right that's
decreasing if it's horizontal that's
constant so I kind of scan from left to
right and I look at where is the graph
going up to the right well it looks like
here and here so what we're interested
in is not the y-values some students
make the mistake of looking at the
y-values we're interested in for what X
values are the Y values increasing so as
I go from left to right see I'm going up
up up up so that's when X is what from
I'm just going to write increasing from
negative infinity to 1 to negative 3
okay
Union okay from when X is 1 and onward
so that's from 1 to positive thing now
the important thing you want to notice
here is see how I use these parentheses
select an open interval and the reason
is is because when you get to negative 3
that's where it's changing from
increasing to decreasing so you don't
want to actually include negative 3 same
thing over here even though this is a
closed point here when you get to 1 its
changing from constant to increasing so
with increasing decreasing constant
you're always going to want to use open
intervals when you're talking about
domain and range that's different and
we'll talk about that at number 17 okay
so I just did increasing for decreasing
you can see it's going down to the right
here and you can see from that's one
from X's from negative 3 all the way to
x equals negative 1 so we're going to
say negative 3 to negative 1 and then
constant I'll just try like a horizontal
line to abbreviate there is when X is
from negative 1 to positive 1 and you
got it okay let's look at number 15 it
says find the relative
maxximum okay so for the same graph so
remember when we talk about relative
maximum relative minimum these are
basically where the graph is bending or
turning and relative to the points that
are in either side
it's the highest now you can see it's
not the absolute maximum this graph
keeps going up but where it's bending
here it's relative to the points that
are on the other side this is a high
point so at negative 3/2 that is our
relative maximum for Part B it says find
F of 2 so what's F of 2 mean well
remember whatever is in the parentheses
that's like our x-coordinate so when X
is equal to 2 f of X is really saying
what's the y-value well you can see the
y-value at when x equals 2 is actually 0
and you got it so let's look at number
16 now it says determine whether the
function is even odd or neither okay so
look here's something you might want to
add your note sheet when you replace
negative x okay I'm sorry when you
replace X with negative x in your
function if you get back the original
function f of X that tells you that the
function is even now what does that mean
even well even means it's going to be
reflection over the y-axis so you could
think of this as y-axis symmetry but we
when we test it in this fashion we call
it even
now if you replace wherever you see X
with negative x and you get negative f
of X meaning like you have the original
function but it's multiplied by negative
1 then we call this an odd function okay
an odd function means it's a rotation
about the origin so what we're going to
do is we're going to take this function
here and we're going to replace X with
negative X let's do that so negative x
so I'm going to put in negative x square
root 2 times negative x squared minus 1
so I'm just doing a substitution
wherever I see ax and replace him with
negative x a negative x squared is just
going to give us positive x squared and
we have negative x so when we look at
this function here what you can see is
you see this right here it's just like
our original function the only
difference is it's multiplied by
negative 1 so that tells us that this is
an odd function and when we go to graph
it we'll see that it's a rotation 180
about the origin okay for number 17 now
we're looking at the domain and the
range so now remember domain means what
can x-values be and the range means what
can the y-values be my technique that I
use when I do this is when I'm looking
at what the domain is I scan from left
to right okay along the x-direction with
a vertical line or like my marker here
so when I scan across see how there's
not any points over here at negative 5
negative 4 negative 3 it's open but 4
negative 3 to 0 see how there's points
on the graph it's crossing there so what
I would say for the domain is it doesn't
include negative 3 but it goes all the
way up to 0 including 0 Union now see
how there's a little bit of a gap here
between 0 & 2 and that picks up at 2 and
greater so we're gonna say from 2 to
positive infinity but you can never
reach infinity that's always going to be
open now when I do the range I take a
horizontal line like this marker marker
and I scan from low to high right so can
I so you can see this keeps going down
down down so I'm going from negative
infinity up to 0 okay and this is open
this is closed so you can see it
continues to cross the graph here right
and then even when you go up here it's
crossing it a half 1 1 & a half 2 and
then up here there's not any point so at
this height at this Y value so you can
see the range is negative infinity all
the way to 2 including 2 but not not
above so that's what I do scan left to
right for domain low to high for range
okay number 18 it says find the average
rate of change from x equals 2 to x
equals 5 for this function right here
now when they say average rate of change
what they're really telling us is they
want us to find the slope so the first
thing we need to do is find the y
coordinates of these two points so that
we can then find the slope between the
two points so what we're gonna do is
we're gonna put 2 into our function in
place of X so we get 3 times 2 squared
plus 2 plus 1 which let's see equals 4
times 3 is 12 plus 2 is 14 plus 1 is 15
okay so we have the point 2 comma 15 and
then if we put 5 in we 3 times 5 squared
plus 5
plus one so that comes out to 25 times 3
is 75 80 81 so now we have the point 5
comma 81 and now we just have to find
the slope and remember the slope is the
difference in the Y's over the
difference in the X's so we have 81
minus 15 over 5 minus 2 and so this
comes out to let's see 81 minus 15
what is that 7 11 6 yeah so 66 divided
by 3 which is a rate of change or a
slope of 22 okay so for number 19 it
says evaluate the greatest integer
function at negative four point one and
then at two point nine nine now if you
see these interesting looking brackets
here that tells us greatest integer
function or sometimes I'll draw it like
this with the little bars on the bottom
which really tells us to round down
basically to the left on the number line
so what I like to do sometimes with
these problems is plot them on the
number line here's negative 4 here's
negative 5 Nick and here's negative 3
negative 4 point 1 is right about there
but we have to round to the left meaning
round down so this is actually negative
5 some students mistakenly will say Oh
4.1 I'm just gonna round down to 4 but
you have to think about the number line
you're rounding to the left the next
integer to the left now if this is
negative 4 then it would just stay at
that integer value negative 4 it's in
between integer values you're gonna have
to round down to the next lowest integer
so for 2.99 let's see here's two here's
three 2.99 it's almost a three but not
quite we have to round down to the next
integer which is going to give us two
okay so for number 20 we're also working
with the greatest integer function see
those brackets again what we're going to
do now is we want to graph this function
using transformations so the key here is
to really be comfortable with you know
how do you shift the graph how do you
stretch the graph compress the graph
reflect the graph but you can see here
if we were to just take a look at our
basic greatest integer function which is
like this let's make a table of values
I'll show you how this works really
quick so say if you had like 0 that
would still be 0.5 that would be 0 0.999
that's going to be 0 and then as soon as
you get to 1 you're at
five would round onto 11.9 would round
down to 1 and 2 would be 2 so if we were
to plot these points what this greatest
integer function looks like is like this
so it's you're gonna be at zero zero
point five you're at zero point nine
nine you're at zero as soon as you get
to one you jump up to the next integer
value which is one okay and so then here
one point five you're at one one point
nine nine you're at one as soon as you
get to two you jump up to the next
integer value so what they call this is
a greatest integer function but
oftentimes referred to as a step
function because it looks like stairs
going going up like that right and you
can once you get a few of the steps you
can repeat that process like I'm doing
now but what we're doing here is you can
see what the two does is going to be
stretching the graph is gonna be
multiplying the Y values by two so these
stairs instead of going up one two three
like that they're gonna be going from
zero to two to four to six so it's
doubling the Y values and this is gonna
be shifting the graph right one see the
minus one the one group of the X has the
opposite effect so minus one is going to
the right one if it was plus one it
would go to the left one and this value
here the two is going to shift the graph
up to so what I'm going to do now is I'm
going to let's do this in step so I'll
see if I can show you how this works so
the first thing I would do is graph
these steps but what I'm going to do is
I'm going to do the stretch first I'm
going to these are going up by two each
time okay like that okay so that's a
vertical stretch and then what we're
gonna do is we're gonna take each of
these steps and move them right one and
up two so this one right here is going
to go right one okay up two
so that actually coincides I know if you
can see this you're going right one up
two same thing here this is going right
one up two so this graph is actually not
looking any different than it does right
now but if you were to describe the
transformations that's how you would do
it it's a shifting right one vertical
stretch by two and then shift up to okay
so for number 21 it says write the
equation for the parent function f of X
equals square root of x when you reflect
it over the y-axis okay and then you
shift up to so what would be the new
equation here well let's call the new
equation G of X
okay and what's happening is when you
reflect over the y-axis like this what
happens is the x-coordinates are they
going to have the opposite sign so it's
going to be multiplied by negative one
so negative of X and then when you shift
up to this is going to be plus two now
notice it's not grouped with the ax when
it's grouped with the ax that's when
it's going to affect the X direction the
horizontal direction when it's not like
out here it's going to affect the
vertical shift up and down if it was
minus two it go down to okay for number
22 now we're working with composition of
functions
we've got f of X equals 2x minus 3 and G
of x equals x squared plus 1 it asks us
what is f of G of two okay so what you
want to do is you want to work from the
inside out so we're gonna start by the
inside the G function and it says put
two into the function on the right in
place of X so 2 squared is 4 plus 1 is 5
so this comes out to 5 now we're finding
out what's f of 5 so again whatever is
in the parentheses goes in for X on the
right that's 2 times 5 is 10 minus 3
which is equal to 7 and you got it so it
kind of like a two-step process for
letter B though what we have is G of f
of X see this little symbol here this
really represents like G of f of X so
another way to write it but what we're
doing is we're putting the F function
into the G function so in this case our
F function is 2x minus 3 and what we're
gonna do is we're going to now take
whatever's in the parenthesis remember
how that goes in for X on the right side
we're going to put 2x minus 3 that
quantity in place of X and square it and
add 1 so this is going to be 2x minus 3
squared plus 1 now if you want to foil
this out it comes out to 4x squared
minus 12x plus 9 plus 1 more which is
plus 10 but you could leave it like that
or like that
either way okay number 23 it says find
the inverse of f of X equals x plus 4
all divided by X minus 3 so remember
when you find the inverse what you want
to do is you want to interchange the X
and Y and solve for the new Y so when
you think of f of X you could think of
this as the Y value so what I'm going to
do is I'm going to interchange the x and
y so we have x equals y plus 4 over y
minus 3 and then what we can do is we
can think of X as X divided by 1
anything divided by 1 is itself and we
can cross
multiply to get rid of the fractions
here so y plus four times one is just
going to be y plus four x times both of
these we have to distribute that's going
to be X Y minus three X what I'm going
to do is I'm going to subtract X Y to
get it on the left side of the equation
I'm going to subtract four to get that
on the right side of the equation now
notice how there's a Y in both of these
terms I want to factor that Y out and
now what I can do instead of x one minus
X I can divide both sides of the
equation by one minus X and we've got it
so now you see how we've got the Y by
itself instead of Y what we could do is
we could write this as half inverse of x
equals this quantity right here okay so
let's go to number 24 it says is the
inverse of this graph here a function so
what they're testing us on here is the
horizontal line test HLT and what you do
is you draw a horizontal lines and you
see does it cross the graph at more than
one point well you can see here this
horizontal line is crossing at this
point at this point this point so that
means it fails the horizontal line test
it means that the inverse of this graph
is not going to be a function when you
do the vertical line test or testing to
see if the original graph passes that
vertical line test if the original graph
is a function the horizontal line test
is testing if the inverse is a function
in this case it fails since the
horizontal line crossed more than once
okay for number 25 and says find the
vertex of the quadratic function f of X
equals negative 2x squared minus 8x plus
5 the important thing here is to
remember this formula negative B over 2a
and remember this is a B and C negative
B over 2a gives us the x coordinate of
the vertex it also gives us the axis of
symmetry of the parabola so for this one
negative B is the opposite of B that's
going to be 8 over 2 times a which is 2
times negative 2 this is negative 4 so
we have 8 over negative 4 which equals
negative 2 now negative 2 that's the
x-coordinate the vertex if we put it
back in we can solve for f of X which is
the y coordinate of the vertex so let's
go ahead and do that we've got negative
2 squared which is 4 times negative 2 is
negative 8 negative 2 times negative 8
is positive 16 plus 5 so we have 21 well
let's do it this way this is 8 plus 5 is
13 so negative 2 13 is your vertex okay
number 26 it says write this function
which is the same when we work with in
number 25 in vertex form by completing
the square okay so to refresh on
completing the square what we're going
to do is we're going to think of f of X
as Y okay
and what I'm going to do is I'm gonna
subtract the 5 to the other side of the
equation just to kind of get it out of
the way so we have Y minus 5 equals
negative 2 x squared minus 8x I'm going
to factor out this leading coefficient
okay so I divided both these by negative
2 factored it out and now what we're
gonna do is we're gonna complete the
square so the way you complete the
square is you take half of B so our B
value is 4 so half of 4 is 2 and then
what you want to do is you want to
square it so 2 squared is 4 but because
it's in parenthesis this is actually
negative 2 times 4 which is negative 8
that we added to the right side of the
equation we have to add negative 8 to
the left side so now we're getting Y
minus 13 equals negative 2 and if we
factor what's inside the parenthesis we
get X plus 2 2 quantity squared now I'm
going to add 13 back to this side to get
the Y by itself and now that's our
vertex form so you can see the vertex is
going to be at negative 2 positive 13
same thing we got here the one this
group of the X has the opposite you know
the opposite effect on the graph so this
is in the form y equals a times X minus
H squared plus K HK is the vertex a is
the stretch compress or reflect in this
case a negative 2 is reflecting it the 2
is stretching it it's opening downward
so you can see the vertex is native to
13 the axis of symmetry goes right
through the x-coordinate of vertex
that's x equals negative 2 the y
intercept what you want to do is you
want to set X equal to 0 so the y
intercept is going to be 0 comma 5 but
to find the x-intercept what you want to
do is you want to set the Y value equal
to 0 okay and solve so in this case what
I would do here is I probably use the
vert the vertex form one here the one
where we completed the square so if y is
equal to zero I'm going to subtract 13
okay so that's negative 13 I'm going to
divide by negative 2
that equals x plus 2 squared so these
negatives cancel and I'm going to take
the square root of both sides
remember when you do that you get two
answers that's plus or minus square root
of we'll just say 13 halves equals x
plus 2 and they're going to subtract 2
so this comes out to negative 2 plus or
minus the square root of 13 halves and
you can simplify that down further but
those are going to be where it crosses
the x-axis the x-intercepts okay so for
number 27 it says write the vertex form
of the parabola with a vertex at
negative 1/3
and passes through the point zero six
okay so here you can see we're working
with this vertex form of the parabola
this one right here HK is the vertex so
we have y equals a times X minus a
negative one squared plus K okay which
is our y coordinate of our vertex now if
we put 6 in for y 0 in for X these two
negatives cancel and give us positive 1
so we get 1 squared is 1 times a is a
subtract 3 you can see a is equal to 3
now if we take the 3 and we put it back
in for a we've got our equation in
vertex form so it's going to be y equals
what a equals which is 3 times X plus 1
squared plus 3 and that's our vertex
form okay for number 28 they're giving
us a function f of x equals x cubed
minus 2 x squared minus 8x and then it
wants to know the end behavior the real
zeros and it wants us to graph it so
we're working with you know graphing
polynomials the first thing I would do
is look at the NBA behavior and what you
want to do is you want to look at that
leading coefficient the leading
coefficient is positive which tells us
that the graph is going up to the right
but because it's an odd degree it means
it's going to be going the opposite
direction to the left if the leading
coefficient is negative it's going to be
going down to the right and if it was an
even degree that two end behaviors are
the same either both down or both up
okay one way you can test this is if you
put like a value in for X so say for
example of X was 10 10 cubed is a
thousand so when you're over here at 10
X is way up here at a thousand so you
can see it's going up this term is
growing faster than these two terms so
you can kind of ignore these this is
going to be the most influential term
if you put negative ten in a negative 10
cube is negative a thousand right so
that's gonna be going you know down to
the left right so it's way down here so
you can test some values just in the
highest powered term but what we're
gonna do is we're going to write it in
the limit notation so we're gonna say
the limit as X approaches infinity
meaning as X goes to the right half of X
which are the Y values are going to go
to positive infinity meaning going up
but if you say the limit as X goes to
negative infinity meaning as you go to
the left what happens to the Y values
well f of X is going down to negative
infinity as far as finding the zeros
what you do is you set the Y value to 0
to find the real zeros and those are
going to be our x-intercepts
so what we do is we just set y equal to
0 and let's factor out an X that's our
greatest common factor okay and let's
see if we can factor this further that's
going to be X minus 4 and X plus 2 okay
so we're just factoring now if we set
each of these groups equal to 0 you can
see that we're going to be getting 0
we're gonna be getting positive 4 1 2 3
4 and we're gonna be getting negative 2
so those are our zeros 0 4 and negative
2 and we already got our end behavior
you can see all these zeros are just
occurring once there's no double zeros
or triple zeros so when we graph it it's
just gonna go right through these points
something like this now this is just a
rough sketch it's got our x-intercepts
it's got the basic shape of the graph
it's got the end behavior if you wanted
to plot some additional points in
between these x-intercepts you could get
a little bit better idea about how far
down this graph goes or how high up it
goes etc but that's a pretty good sketch
ok number 29 it says find a fifth degree
polynomial with zeros at x equals 1 2
and negative 3 so the important thing
that they're testing us on here is they
give us the zeros but how do we find the
polynomial well X minus the zeros are
the factors so of x equals 1 is a 0 X
minus 1 is a factor if a 2 is a 0 X
minus 2 is a factor if negative 3 is a 0
X minus negative 3 is a factor but the
two negatives cancel so it becomes X
plus 3 so if you set these groups equal
to 0 these factors to 0 you're gonna get
you know these zeros right here 1 2 and
negative 3 but notice if you were to
multiply these together it's only going
to come out to X cube do we really want
this to be a fifth degree polynomial so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
make this one squared and that one
squared so there's more than one correct
answer but you can see now if you add
these exponents two plus two plus one
that gives us a fifth degree polynomial
with the zeros one to a negative three
now two here is going to be what they
call it double zero or K or a 2 with
multiplicity two meaning it occurs twice
same thing with negative three negative
three is a double zero or negative three
has a multiplicity of 2 meaning it
occurs twice for number 30 now it says
divide 3x cubed minus five x squared
plus X plus 2 by X plus 3 what they're
testing us on here is we can either do
the polynomial long division or because
this is a linear factor we can do the
synthetic division we're going to do
negative 3 here and we're use the
coefficients of our polynomial 3
negative 5 1 & 2 now if it skips over
from X cube to X for example you'd want
to put a placeholder of a zero there you
want to make sure it goes in descending
order and if any terms are missing again
put that zero as a placeholder when you
divide by X plus 3 you want to use the
opposite sign here negative 3 if this
was X minus 3 I would make this a
positive 3 and then what you do is you
drop down that first term okay
negative 3 times 3 is negative 9 add
those together multiplying the diagonal
add straight down multiply on the
diagonal let's see what does this come
out to negative 129 and add straight
down negative 127 this last number is
the remainder we started with x cubed it
goes down by one degree this is 3x
squared minus 14x plus 43 plus a
negative 127 okay divided by X plus 3 so
whatever the remainder is it's over the
divisor what you're dividing by instead
of plus a negative I could just write
this as minus okay for number 31 it says
use the remainder theorem to find f of 5
given that f of X equals this polynomial
here so the remainder theorem is very
similar to the synthetic division so
what you would do is you put 5 over here
and you put the coefficients of your
polynomial for
negative two there's not an x squared
term so I'm gonna put a placeholder zero
to X and 3 and then we just do our like
our synthetic division it we bring down
the 4 we multiply in the diagonal we add
straight down we multiply on the
diagonal we add straight down we
multiply on the diagonal we add straight
down we multiply in the diagonal let me
go to the calculator on this one I did
this one a little bit earlier is 2260 if
we add straight down we get two thousand
two hundred and sixty-three and this
last number here is the output so
basically when you put five in to your
function you're going to get out 2263
you could also do this direct
substitution put 5 in for X and simplify
but this is the remainder theorem is
like a little bit of a quicker way to
find out what that output is using the
same method we did when we did synthetic
division so the last number is our
output so f of 5 is 2260 3 okay for 32
it says simplify and write in a plus bi
form 3 plus 2i divided by 4 minus I well
we don't want to have I in the
denominator just like how we don't want
to have a square root in the denominator
so to get rid of this I in the
denominator what we're going to do is
we're gonna multiply it by the complex
conjugate we change that sign in between
these two terms so this was plus I'd
make that minus I now all we have to do
is just foil okay as if you're
multiplying two binomials together so if
we do that let's see what we get 3 times
4 is 12 the outer gives us 3i the inner
gives us 8 I so that's gonna be 11 I 2 I
times I gives us 2 I squared okay and
then over here in the denominator we
have first terms give us 16 outer 4 i
inner negative 4i those cancel in the
last two terms we get negative I squared
now remember I squared is equal to
negative 1 this is very important and
remember I represents a square root of
negative 1 so when we see this I squared
here we can replace it with negative 1
so that's negative 1 times 2 is negative
2 plus 12 is 10 and here we have I
squared is negative 1 times a negative
is positive 1 plus 16 is 17 but we don't
want to leave it in this form we want to
actually split this up into two parts
10 over 17 plus 11 over
17 I that's what they call the a plus bi
form it's the real part plus the
imaginary part okay for number 33 now it
says list all possible rational zeros
rational means a ratio right can be
written as a fraction of an integer or
an integer for f of X equals this
polynomial so the rational root theorem
or rational zero theorem however you
learn it whichever name you take all the
factors of the constant over all the
factors of the leading coefficient like
this you would say all the numbers would
go into five which would be plus or
minus one or plus or minus five divided
by all the factors that go into the
leading coefficient here which are plus
or minus one or plus or minus three so
now if we write these values down it
could be 1 over 1 which is a negative 1
it can be positive 1 let's see it could
be let's see negative 5 positive 5
it could be one third or it could be
negative one third alright so I
basically I'm taking any numerator over
any denominator so did I get them all
one over one 1 over 3 ok 5 over 1 and fo
we forgot 5 over 3 so 5/3 and negative
5/3 and if you want you can put them in
order from lowest to highest that's
oftentimes helpful but again any
numerator with any denominator okay for
number 34 it says find all the rational
zeros of this function so what we're
going to do is we're going to use our
rational root theorem a rational zero
theorem to narrow down the possible
rational roots so we're going to take
all the factors of eight over all the
factors of 1 so B plus or minus the
numbers are going to eat like one two
four and eight over all the numbers that
go into one which are just plus or minus
one so this works out pretty easy it
could be 1 or negative 1 2 or negative 2
4 negative 4 8 or negative 8 but what
we're going to do is we're going to test
them out using synthetic division so
let's just say if we wanted to see if
one was a zero we're going to take the
coefficients of our polynomial and just
do the synthetic division so bring down
one multiplying the diagonal add
straight down multiply on the diagonal
add straight down multiply on the
diagonal and straight down
notice how we got zero remainder that
tells us that 1 is a zero meaning that 1
is an x-intercept ok and X minus 1 is a
factor but when we do the synthetic
division remember this bring this
brings this polynomial down by one
degree and we could factor this further
2x minus 4x plus 2 and then 1 so this
would be like X minus 1 because since
that was a 0 so we fully factored it so
our zeros would be 1 4 and negative 2
that's where it's gonna cross the x-axis
so you want to try to bring it down to a
second-degree quadratic so that you can
either do the quadratic formula or you
can factor it to find the remaining
zeros here we start off with a third
degree so we really couldn't factor this
so that's why we did a rational root
theorem so for 35 it says find a
polynomial function with real
coefficients okay that have to I and
negative 1 as zeros now the interesting
thing is is that notice how if we want
to write a polymer with real
coefficients and we have an imaginary
zero like a complex zero then what that
tells us is that the complex conjugate
will also be a zero so if 2i is a zero
we also know the negative 2i is a zero
or if we had like a plus bi is a zero
then we would know that a minus bi is a
zero they come as conjugate pairs if the
coefficients of the polynomial are going
to be real like that so so here let's go
ahead and write this out we know that X
minus two I is a factor since two I is
zero we know X minus negative two I is a
factor since negative 2i is a zero and
we know X minus negative one is a factor
since negative one is a zero so it's
always X minus a zero so if we simplify
this a little bit this will become plus
2i this would become plus one let's foil
this out so it first gives us x squared
the inside and outside cancel negative
two times I times positive 2 I is
negative four I squared okay which that
comes out to negative one times negative
4 is positive 4 so we have x squared
plus 4 times X plus 1 so here if we foil
this we get X to the third outer gives
us x squared inner gives us 4x and the
last term's give us 4 so this would be
our polynomial function f of x equals x
cubed plus x squared plus 4x plus 4 so
the key was really to recognize the
complex conjugates concept if the
coefficients are real okay number 36 it
says f of x equals x squared
- four all over x squared minus 2x minus
eight
we want to basically graph this rational
function finding the domain asymptotes
the holes the X intercepts the y
intercepts etc so the first thing I
recommend doing is when you have a
problem like this is see f---ing and
factor it as much as you can so the
first thing I would do is factor in the
numerator x + 2 x - 2 and in factor the
denominator which is X - 4 and X + 2 now
notice how that X plus 2's cancel
numerator and denominator so what that
tells us when you have a factor in the
top and the bottom that cancel out is
that there's going to be a whole
oftentimes referred to as a removable
discontinuity at this value negative 2
so if you said X plus 2 equal to 0 you
get negative 2 that's going to be the x
coordinate of the hole and so what you
can do now is take the negative 2 and
put it back into your equation in place
of X so negative 2 minus 2 is negative 4
negative 2 minus 4 is negative 6 and
that reduces to 2/3 so that's the y
coordinate of our hole so let's go ahead
and plot that on our graph negative 2
2/3 that's right about there draw an
open circle okay the next thing I would
want to do is look at the asymptotes so
the asymptotes first thing I do is look
at the denominator you can see that the
denominator cannot be zero that's
undefined so if we set X - 4 equal to 0
we get x equals 4 that's our vertical
asymptote 1 2 3 4 and we can draw that
as a dashed or dotted line at 4 now for
the horizontal asymptote what we do is
we look at the highest degree term in
the numerator and the highest degree
term in the denominator notice it's a
tie they're both x squared so we look at
the ratio of the coefficient so 1 over 1
gives us a horizontal asymptote at y
equals 1 so that's gonna look something
like like that
now if the degree in the denominator was
higher like if this was X cubed and that
was x squared then it would be y equals
0 is our horizontal asymptote right at
the x axis and if the numerators power
was higher like if this was X cubed and
this was x squared then we would
actually get a slant or a diagonal
asymptote and we'd have to do the
polynomial long division to find a
equation of that slant asymptote
so now let's take a look at the domain
so the domain is whatever the x-values
can be the main thing here is we don't
want the denominator to be zero because
you can't divide by zero that's
undefined so X cannot be a 4 and X
cannot be negative 2 so sometimes you
can draw this on the number line that
helps so negative 2 or 4 we don't want
those values but it could be everything
else so if we want to write this in
interval notation we could say the
domain is from negative infinity to
negative 2 not including negative 2 so
we're using the parenthesis not the
bracket and then from negative 2 to
positive 4 not including positive 4 and
Union 4 to infinity so that's going to
be your domain now as far as the
x-intercepts go if we want to find the
x-intercepts what we really want to do
is we want to set y equal to 0 the only
way that Y will be 0 is if the numerator
of this fraction is equal to 0 so by
setting the numerator to 0 X minus 2 is
equal to 0 then we get x equals 2 our
x-intercept is at 2 0 so that's going to
cross right there the y-intercept what
we can do is we can set the x value
equal to 0 so if we put 0 in for X we
get negative 4 over negative 8 which is
positive 1/2 and so that's going to be
our y-intercept right there so now you
can see that the graph is going along
like this and then it goes like that
approaches the asymptotes and if we plot
some additional points like say for
example x equals 5 we get 3 over 1 which
is 3 so at 5 you're at 3 right here so
you can kind of see the graph is going
to look something like that
so these are like the two branches of
our rational function so for number 37
it says solve the inequality so here
what you want to do is you want to get
everything on one side of the inequality
sign and set it to 0 then what you want
to do is you want to factor it as much
as you can and set those factors equal
to 0 so if we set them equal to 0 we get
negative 3 ok for this one if we said
this one is 0 we get x equals 4 but see
how it's less than 0 it doesn't want to
equal 0 that means that these are going
to be open meaning it doesn't include
these values now what we're gonna do is
we're going to do something called sign
analysis and we're going to pick a test
value and each one of
these intervals okay so say we test like
for example like negative for if I put
negative 4 in here I'm gonna get a
negative 8 which is negative a negative
4 plus 3 is negative 1 which is negative
a negative times a negative is a
positive so I'm just going to put a plus
sign here but we really want a negative
value we want something that it's less
than a zero okay but now let's pick a
number in this interval let's say like
for example 0 if we put 0 in here we get
0 minus 4 which is negative 0 plus 3
which is positive 3 a negative times a
positive is a negative now let's pick
another point in this interval let's
just say like 5 5 minus 4 is 1 that's
positive 5 plus 3 is 8 that's positive a
positive times a positive is a positive
we want where the graph is less than 0
meaning where it's negative so that's
going to be from negative 3 to 4 not
including negative 3 not including 4 so
that would be the interval that would
make this inequality true now if we were
to graph this in like 2 dimensions what
you would see is that this is actually a
parabola ok x squared minus X minus 12
it's opening up like that and so here
you can see is where it's below the
x-axis okay over here is where it's
above meaning where it's positive or
greater than zero but we're just
analyzing on the number line in one
dimension so for number 38 a last
problem here we want to solve this
inequality but what you want to do is
you want to get a common denominator
when these into one fraction so I'm
going to multiply the numerator and
denominator by X minus 1 so that's going
to give us negative 3x plus 3 I'm just
just doing the negative 3 this is X plus
2 all over our common denominator X
minus 1 so if we combine like terms we
get negative 2x 2 plus 3 is 5 and we
want this to be less than or equal to 0
so now what you're going to do with
these rational inequalities is you're
going to set the numerators factors and
the denominators factored is equal to 0
so if we do that we get X minus 1 equals
0 that's going to be x equals 1 if we
set the numerators factor to 0 we're
going to get let's see negative 5
divided by negative 2 that's going to be
5 halves okay that's like 2 and 1/2 and
we want it to be less than or equal to 0
the important thing to pay attention to
those in the denominator can never equal
0 right
because that would be undefined so this
is going to be open meaning it can't
include one can't be one but the
numerator can equal zero five halves so
this is going to be closed I mean it
includes that point now we're going to
pick points in each of these intervals
starting with let's say maybe zero is a
good point here so if we'd put in zero a
negative 2 times 0 is 0 plus 5 is 5
that's positive 0 minus 1 is negative 1
that's negative a positive divided by
negative is a negative let's say we pick
for example 2 is in this interval an a
of 2 times 2 is negative 4 plus 5 is 1
that's positive two minus one is one
that's positive a positive divided by a
positive is a positive and let's just
say we pick like 10 okay so we did
negative 20 plus 5 is negative 15 that's
negative and we said 10 minus 1 is 9
that's positive we have a negative of a
positive which is negative we want to
know where it's less than or equal to
zero we knew where it's negative or a
zero so this is going to be negative
infinity to 1 not including 1 and from 5
halves to positive infinity this
includes 5 halves we want to use a
bracket for that whereas the other ones
we're using parentheses because it
doesn't include those points so great
job I hope this helps you review for the
first quarter precalculus exam if you
want to see quarter number two I'm going
to be doing a video for that and you can
check that out right over there
otherwise if there were concepts here
that you didn't understand or want more
review on I have all these concepts on
my Morrow's math tutor YouTube channel
I'll see you in the next video